are you working on some uh
something with a wwe now or well we did
we produced
one of these these a e biographies that
are premiering i think they're
premiering like
soon right um yeah like in the next
couple weeks or so
um we did the one on the ultimate
florida man
macho man randy savage which by the way
that could have been his name florida
man randy savage would have been a name
he's not from down here but he he very
much became
a consummate florida man uh and so we
produced
uh executive produce the um the randy
savage
uh a w i don't know how they're branding
it but like a
e w e biography kind of a 30 for 30 of
uh
of wwe superstars did you his uh
the tree his memorial of the tree he
wrecked into and
when he died is like five minutes down
the road from where i am right now
oh no [ __ ] yeah i've had his brother on
this podcast
oh he's a character man we went to so i
was not far from you
a couple years ago when we shot that i
guess in 2019-ish um
he um we went to his place
um yeah uh and and interviewed lonnie
there um
and then went to we went to the of
course film b-roll
at the tree i mean i i think you know
he wrecked into it but i think he was
probably dead before he
before he hit the tree um oh i thought
he died in the hospital afterwards
i mean he i guess my point is i don't
think it was the accident
the crash rather that killed him i think
he he was having a medical episode
and they were driving into oncoming
traffic and and randy's widow
lynn to her credit i mean quick thinking
in the moment while randy's kind of i
guess seizing up or whatever
she realized like we could kill some
we're driving into oncoming traffic
she turned the wheel into the tree in
front of the church
basically yeah to stop them from god
forbid taking anybody else
out um but but randy was already in
you know in the midst of a a medical you
know episode you know
um when they jumped the curve and you
know the uh the median rather and went
into oncoming traffic yeah
oh my god man i watched the uh the dark
side of the ring thing that vice did on
it
yeah that was [ __ ] stunning man to
hear about just like
like all like the the relationship
between him and hulk
was insane just like all the jealousy
all the cr you know when they would
travel and and
you know all the fights he would get in
with and how he'd be so jealous of his
fiancee
when she would go hang out with hulk and
his wife and
man that was he so we we interviewed
terry
um in saint pete uh actually uh for
you know i i love tampa tampa is the
florida of florida
it is it's real florida miami is not
florida by the way yeah
miami's nothing like any other place in
florida miami and key west are
out they're like different countries
absolutely yeah and
and they you know what you know they say
in uh florida the further north you go
the further south you are
oh yeah absolutely yeah but i like tampa
uh a lot
and um the so i get to spend a lot of
time
there obviously i mean listen uh i think
wrestling is the my my friend uh
mike lawrence says wrestling is the
florida of sports um
you know and tampa is the florida
florida so it's only appropriate that
you know wrestling has such a profound
uh presence
you know in and around uh tampa and st
pete and so
um we uh um
i think we tried to bring a little bit
of that florida flavor and that
tampa you know bay area flavor
to the dock and i hopefully you'll see
it in a couple of you know a couple of
the pods
uh but um interestingly oh yeah we
we we talked to michael who was um
hulk's
costume designer back when hulk was in a
band
in tampa you know when he was a kid and
then he went on to do
jimi hendrix um all the iconic whether
it was like
the cover of magazines or woodstock uh
he he dressed jimi hendrix
he dressed a bunch of like um rock and
soul acts
he dressed all the pimps of tampa the
spanish here
what is it yeah he does yeah back in the
70s and 80s he'd be a great interview
for you
70s and 80s did all the pimps of tampa
and i said to myself mike i said looking
at randy savage's costumes i'm like
it's kind of like cowboy pimp right i
mean like a lot
and he had never thought of it because
he just you get inspiration and you you
try different things on someone to see
how it fits and how it
uh you know reflects the persona and
he's like yeah it is kind of cowboy pimp
is kind of the look of it you know and
of course the pimps of tampa
influenced randy savage's famous uh
wardrobe so we get into that which is
probably kind of new information but
what's interesting is that
the relationship between uh
uh you know terry and linda
and uh uh randy and
um and elizabeth all come to a head
and are completely really uh
disintegrate
in miami um and
it happened oh yeah they were on
vacation down here down there
hulk was shooting mr nanny the movie mr
nanny
and he was shooting knights and so uh
linda came with the kids they stayed at
this condo hotel called the jockey club
in like the north miami
area and she invited
uh linda the hulk hogan's wife invited
uh ex-wife now but at the time invites
miss elizabeth to come down
with them to chill like we you know uh
you know you can you can cry we have
plenty of a big apartment plenty of
rooms you can crash with us help me
watch the kids
um and um
and so she does now what
linda and hulk didn't know was that
randy and elizabeth miss elizabeth were
on the outs and that elizabeth was
actually leaving randy or running
away from randy and so and randy doesn't
know this
and so they come down and they're at the
jockey club
terry tells this whole story himself in
his own words in the dark
and he's coming home from
set shooting nights in the morning and
he's noticing
that miss elizabeth's bedroom is empty
and he's like where is miss elizabeth
and he says to lindy goes if she's out
playing around or whatever
he said i don't want to get into it with
randy we need to get her her own hotel
room she can do her own you know her own
thing
like i can't be responsible for whatever
is going on so they get her a hotel room
in the building her own
hotel room and within days
randy is banging cop the cop bang you
know the
you know that that fbi is 6 a.m on the
door back you know
banging open up yeah and open up
elizabeth
well good that's pretty good and still
and terry
kerry answers the door in his in his in
his towel
and he is on a rampage uh
randy and he says listen brother he's
not she you know
she's not here she's got her own room i
don't know they go down and apparently
she's in there with the tennis pro from
the jockey club
which has a whole bunch of like
professional tennis courts and because
miami uh in the 80s or then early night
in the early 90s um and
a ton of cops show up it is an absolute
i mean he's
ripping the room apart allegedly and
it's just as [ __ ]
and that was the not only the beginning
of the end of their marriage uh
miss elizabeth and randy but the
beginning of the end of
uh the hulk and and randy uh friendship
that's incredible that the real life
bled into
the theatrics of the actual what happens
in the ring and the whole storyline of
it
you always wonder how real it is what's
that
the roids probably don't help no hell no
that makes you so [ __ ] aggro but so
wait was elizabeth in the room with the
tennis player
when randy came in that's i think that's
what terry told us that's
that's uh that's his story and he's
sticking to it uh but i do know
i know because my family lived there at
another building at the time
they remember the scene like the police
start you know it's not often that like
a line of cops you know a parade
of of cops show up to this to this uh
condo um development and so like it was
a it was a memorable
event for people who you know lived in
and around there
you